[Music]
last week the state of Idaho held their
Republican governor toriel primary
debate and the Idaho GOP allowed some
fringe candidates to participate in the
debate now people are saying that was a
big mistake because it got a little
strange and it undermined the importance
of the debate I'll show you a clip see
what you think this has been in
lightning debate but it's time for our
closing remarks governor otter you'll go
first together we can achieve our vision
of Idaho that is safer more prosperous
and more United than ever before I'm
butch Otter and I'm humbly asking for
your vote on May 20th thank you thank
you now we'll hear from Harley Brown
okay after God told me it was gonna make
me president I've got the presidential
seal tattooed right here in my shoulder
I was living in fat Jack's cellar
because my wot ex-wife of truck give me
trumped-up thank you for that mr. Brown
mr. BAE's your closing remarks you
remember Chernobyl when you translate
that into English it comes out wormwood
wormwood it is mentioned in the Bible a
whole lot for your study in these last
days and it radiations you know baby man
thank you please vote for me
bird tuxedo start with Sydney
[Music]
[Applause]
good
[Applause]